vertical models we have antonio blanca
from penn state
telling us about hardness of identity
testing for some interesting families of
graphical models
hi everyone thanks for the invitation
and
for organizing the the workshop to the
organizers
so yes i'm going to talk about the
computational complexity of
[Music]
identity testing for in the context of
spin systems and in particular for for
the pod small
and rbm so restricted boltzmann machines
okay so the pots model
was at least defined in
an earlier talk and one for one of the
special cases
but let's go through this slightly more
general definition so
here we are given a finite graph g
and there is a set of spins or colors uh
one through q
we're also given an uh an edge
potential essentially it's a function
beta
from the edges of the graph to the reals
and
this uh this function uh essentially
captures the
strength of the interactions between the
endpoints of the edges
in the graph and statistical mechanics
corresponds to the
inverse temperature of the system
we also have another function that this
one corresponds to an
external magnetic field and in
it's again a general form it's a
function from
the set of vertices uh times the
the spins to to the real number so
essentially for every vertex we may have
a different uh
vertex potential and depending on the
spin
that this vertex is assigned it gets a
different part
okay so now the configurations are the
set
of assignments from the from the spins
to the vertices
of the graph so we can think of all the
q colorings of the graph
each cue coloring will receive a
probability
and this probability is given by the
gibbs distribution
which is uh given by this expression
here
and essentially we look at given so for
configuration sigma
the probabilities is it's
given by some weight or some
normalization constant
and the way essentially has a factor
exponentially in b to the b divided in
the edge
provided that the end points of the edge
have the the same spin
right so for every edge they have the
same spin on the edge
[Music]
on the end points at some points where
this be the
uh video of the edge and then we also go
through
all the vertices and we uh
there is a factor e to the uh the value
of the magnetic field for the vertex
and the spin that is assigned to the
vector okay so
we saw some uh
uh special case uh when there were only
when there are only two spins this is
this corresponds to the to the ac mode
and in many cases we will
look at uh simple versions of
of this uh gibbs distribution where for
example we will assume sometimes that
this is just a constant we always have
the same
parameter beta uh
the same edge interaction beta or all
the edges and sometimes we'll look at
the gate so there is no stem and field
right but this is the the most general
definition and as i said
c here is just a normalization constant
to make mu
for a distribution and it's also known
as the partition function
in solitary physics okay so here is an
example
uh we have q equals three we have three
spins the graph here is the four by four
grid
uh we're going to assume that the h
potential is just a constant function
beta
and then there is no stagnant field so
the probability of this configuration
here
is given by uh it's going to be e to the
six beta over the partition function
and that's because you see that there
are two two red edges here
one one green and and three blue edges
so let's
do a six beta here in this configuration
we only
uh flip the the the the spin of this
vertex here so we lose three of the
edges so
three of the monochromatic edges so now
you get e to the three vital
or the partition function okay so as i
mentioned
uh the pots model is the standard
generalization of the
classical easy mode to multi-spins so we
allow more more
than two spins uh for easy mode we
usually think of the spins
as being plus and minus but we can also
think of the of them as being red and
blue and then it corresponds to
too small when you have uh just two
spins the easy mode
it's a very it's very old it goes to
to the work of uh lens and ethan in the
1920s when
they were trying to explain uh some
phenomena that actually uh pierre curry
observed in his phd thesis corresponding
to some phase transitions of the fertile
magnet
so they were trying to come up with some
statistical mechanics models from to
understand uh this this phase transition
they came up with the mold that
the young calvary worked for them but
then in the later in the 1950s
uh them all was shown to actually be
quite useful
they were just looking in the they were
just considering their own dimensions
we only consider one dimensional case
okay
so since then yeah we demo got
generalized to a pod small there are
many other
standard generalizations and many
applications now
not only in statistical physics in
computer vision
computational biology felony and
it has been also important in
computational learning theory
so here is some more um definitions and
terms that i'll be using through to the
talk
because the uh the mall behave quite
differently
when all the edges are positive
the edge interactions are positive this
this is called the ferromagnetic case
and in this case the mole is attractive
in the sense that
uh edges will encourage the the its
endpoints to have the same color
at the same spin and the opposite
happens when
all these uh when beta is negative then
the mole is called antipheromagnetic and
it's repulsive so here
the edges will actually encourage these
agreements in some points
and another regular classification here
that would be important when we consider
the computation compressive of various
problems it's
uh whether the field is consistent or
not
and we say that they might the center
field is consistent when it favors the
the same spin
in in every vertex right so
for example in the case of the easy mode
we
want to feel that the feel is consistent
when it favors always plus or always
minus
in the in the configuration and the bot
small we want
more generally in the bottom we want the
field is consistent when it's always
failing red
we're always and green and so on okay
otherwise the field is called
inconsistent
okay so in this talk and in this line of
work in general
the goal is to understand the
computational complexity of
of various fundamental problems in
concern related to the spin systems
and yeah i think the the most
interesting
aspect to me would be to understand the
the connections like like
when one of this program is hard what it
does is set out the hardness of
of the other okay so let's start from
maybe
the most fundamental of them which is
the the sampling problem right so now
here we are given the graph
the number of spins the edge
the edge potential the edge weights the
the second field
and our goal our goal is to produce a
sample from the distribution from the
gibbs distribution or from a
distribution that is close to this
distribution
so this is a very well stored problem in
empirically and and theoretically for
the pharmaceutical symbol
when it's like remember magnetic means
that the
edge interaction is always positive for
the case when there is no feel
of the field is consistent there is this
uh classical result
of german sinclair in id3 where they
show that
there is a polynomial in time algorithm
for for sampling
the running time of the algorithm is a
large polynomial
on the size of the graph
but unfortunately this is
the best we have right now for general
graphs there have been some more
attempts some more
algorithms very very different they
still
provide large polynomial times um
the conjecture is that this is doable uh
in sublinear time or very very close to
linear time
but we are far from proving that uh our
progress here
has been in understand in providing
faster samplers for
a specific family of graph or on the sum
assumptions some very assumptions on
beta and an h on on the standard field
okay now if we
now consider the roman existing mole but
instead of
instead of having a feel no no no feel
or a consistent feel we don't see the
case of an inconsistent view
the complexity of the sampling problem
changes and it turns out there is no
approximate sampler unless we have an sp
graph for
char b's it's the result of goldberg
jerome and char b's is this
problem of counting independent sets on
bipartite graph
and i believe the conjecture is that the
community conjecture is that this
is a problem that has an intermediate
complexity
and plays a role in approximate counting
and sampling
again to the unique games in approximate
optimization problems or
ppad for the computation of nash
equilibrium
okay okay so that's for the
ferromagnetic case for the
antiferromagnetic case
the the situation is less promising
because
here even when we have no feel uh
we know that it's mp hard to generate
approximate samples so
yeah and for the ferromagnetic pots
model that's
uh it's going to be our main um
our our main mall of focus today
um so remember for the chromatic
postmode we need at least
three spins um the situation is uh
much less complete like we have a less
uh
much less understanding of what's going
on with the sampling problem
we know that there is a fast sampler
when beta is below some constant some
constant is the so-called division
uniqueness constant that is a function
of the maximum degree of the graph
but we also know that above
a certain threshold the problem becomes
bizarre
so it's uh it's hard to generate samples
uh for beta above a certain threshold
and in in the in this window between the
evolution uniqueness and
and the already solder phase transition
which is these big data points
we have some conjectures we have some
algorithms for some special cases but
it's in general
in general an open question okay so this
is a
quick timer on the sampling problem
the second uh problem that it's going to
be relevant to this talk is
counting but in a sense this is
equivalent it's going to be more or less
equivalent to us
to the sampling problem because we
mostly will be focused on the
approximate question we want to
understand
uh approximate sampling and it turns out
that there are polynomial relations
between approximate sampling and
approximate countess
and this goes back to the work of uh
jerome valenbarani and this this also
for many more including the ones that
we're going to be talking today
okay so that's uh scouting
by the way just uh what this means is
that if uh another way of thinking of
this is that if we have
highness results for counting they apply
for for sampling
and by search okay so
the third problem and this is a problem
that uh it's
more relevant to to the theme of this
workshop
is the structural learning problem and
here we're giving a sampling access to
the gibbs distribution and we hold to
learn the graph g
and we now have an algorithm for
for this problem right so given
given samples we can learn not only the
graph but also the parameters we can
also learn beta and h uh there is there
are many works uh
that lead to this result that led to
this result but now we have this
algorithm that works um
that is exponential on the sparsity of
the mole times
n square log n n is the number of
vertices and
the sparsity of the mole is essentially
the max degree times the maximum
value of beta in absolute value times
plus the
maximum stigma feel also in magnitude
okay and this result is tight um
more or less tight there is a much lower
bound due to
uh theraman
and this is a problem that uh
many folks in in the audience have uh
done uh
um very nice work on and i'm i'm
hopeful i hopefully i don't uh i try to
put the
the most uh significant results here but
uh if i
if i miss any uh i apologize um
but this is uh some of the work on on
structural learning that led to this
tight result
right or some variations of it okay so
finally we get to identity testing so
this is the
slightly different problem and this is
going to be truly our focus
so here i'm going to define it slightly
informal i'll be more formal in a couple
of slides
but we have the specification of a mole
so we call this small m and by
specification
means that we have all the edge weights
vertex weights the graph everything
and we're giving a sample access to a
hidden distribution
and start here we don't get to see them
all but we get to see iid samples from
the mode
and we want to verify we want to say
whether
this hidden mo is equal to the
to the visible more or they are far
apart in flow operation distance
okay so some non-results for this
problem so the
the most uh relevant one and is this
work by
the uh scalars the calendar but they
essentially show that
if you can efficiently sample from the
vc mode mode
then there is an efficient algorithm for
identity testing
okay and a circularity of this is
for example we know how to since we know
how to efficiently generate samples
from the phenomena in small with a
consistent field
or with no external field then we get
an efficient tester for efficient
identity tester for the
pharmaceutical symbol and here by
efficiency
we mean running polynomial that's when i
say efficiency efficient
throughout the talk i will mean uh
volume at all in time
okay and this result here one way of
thinking about it is uh
is that this is reduction that says
whenever something is cc then
testing is easy to yeah
there is another sympathy option that
comes from uh
reducing to using uh structural learning
to
to identity testing right um
sorry not normal reduction but
essentially any and
if you have an efficient uh structural
learning then you can efficiently
uh uh test right and this is not the
right uh learning is
this should be a harder problem than
identity testing and the idea is that
you can use your learner to learn
the mo and then just compare where the
hidden mode is
is equal to the visible mode or not
right this is a very
uh
inefficient way of doing the testing
okay but recall that
we have an structural learning algorithm
uh
say the algorithms like mega now we have
others that that they can do this task
of learning
in exponential on the sparsity times and
square logan
so in particular when the sparsity is
is bounded by logan we end up with with
a polynomial time
testing algorithm okay and here is a
conjecture of my collaborators and
myself
after working on after studying the
harness of this
identity testing for spin system we
started to get this this
this vibe that whenever sampling and
structural learning are hard
identity destiny is also hard right
and we with the one side of the
implication
is clear right when when we can sample
we already know that we can test
and if we can do sexual learning we can
also test
uh and this talk and this line of work
is trying to understand the
the other direction right so in cases
where we know that sampling and
structural learning are hard and
we want to show that identity destiny is
also hard
okay so before i study some of the
results let me just
give you just a slightly more formal
definition of identity testing and in
general we're going to be
doing an interesting on a class on a
family of models
so for example we can consider the class
of uh
of q state port small on inverter graph
of bounded degree by d
where the edge interaction are bounded
by beta and in absolute value
and the field the standard field is
bounded
in magnitude also by h now the
the problem becomes given a mole
given a all from the family if this is a
visual mall
and sample access to some other uh mall
in the family
we want to distinguish probably the
constant at least three quarters
where uh where the moles are the same or
where they are far apart
in collaboration distance okay and
we are going to substitute
uh from pronoun this is the sparsity
parameter of the mole
we're going to actually break it down
and write it as beta times d plus
plus h with the is the max integration
strength
then this is the maximum degree and then
you have the field okay
okay so this is uh this was our first
result in in this uh
in this line of work it's a it's from
last year
but we look at the problem of uh
identity testing for the anti-fragmented
symbol remember the ferromagnetic
case we we more or less understand this
uh concern the active antifarmatic case
and we showed that when this when
when beta d was uh little omega of log n
this means that
uh essentially beta d over log n uh goes
to
infinity so this is growing a little
faster than logan
and there is no standard field then we
have no
no efficient uh i need this identity
algorithm unless
rp equals mp right so
yes so remember that when beta is or log
n
we have an efficient tester so this is
getting
quite close to the to the to the
traction right so we
can put here any slowly growing function
times low n and our result will hold
rp it's uh randomized polygonal time and
in just in the
in the notation from the previous slide
essentially here we're showing that
again this thing is
uh it's hiding this subclass where we
have noise enough field only two spins
and in addition we only consider graphs
where all the edges
are negative so these are
anti-antipheromonadine moles
so this was the first evidence uh
that this conjecture
might be true but it was just a point uh
one data point so in this work we
provide a little more evidence to this
conjecture
and we do i think we do give more
evidence
in a more systematic way right because i
think we we now give
kind of a recipe for showing this this
type of hardness
results okay so our result here concerns
the ferromagnetic pot small
again we have to assume that um
this is another assumption that beta
times this is omega
n q has really three q equals two is the
easy mode
and we since this is an energy so this
is even more interesting when you have
noise and a few so we take h equals zero
and on the for this type of moles for
this family of moles of chromatic
put small under these conditions we show
that there is no efficient
identity in algorithm unless there is an
effect for charities okay so this is the
base hardness of the
of the identity identifying problems for
for programmatic possible
remember that childbirth is the problem
of countless independence section by
part a graph
and also this is tight in a sense that
somewhat tight because when b is uh or a
low end then
the the structure learning algorithm
kicks in and we can solve this problem
be a structure
okay so i'm going to now give you uh the
proof of review but
maybe it's a good time to pause on and
ask if there are any questions
about the framework
yeah i have a super quick question um
for you antonio so so uh
uh when you say structure learning
you're allowed to have very weak edges
right but do you not care about those
um where are you assuming that all the
edges have strength beta
so what in particular like uh
so okay so when beta d oh i see so
you're saying like i'm only
uh assuming that beta is sort of log n
but you could
have very weak weak edges
you could have very weak edges which
would then be hard to learn
but maybe that doesn't matter for your
application
or just for the testing application
right i think uh
we don't uh we okay we don't deal with
those in the sense that when we prove
hardness
we don't put those edges in there
right for the highest result i guess
your question is for the
reduction of uh using the structural
learning for testing right
yeah exactly exactly so this i guess
this is just you're saying this is
true in a regime that's comes up
against the hardness result it doesn't
necessarily fill out the whole space
that's right yeah that's right okay cool
perfect thank you
there is another it's another question
but i cannot access it so
okay the question is uh can you explain
more on how structure learning implies
efficient identity testing
right so
i guess this is a little to the curtain
question my
non-non x-ray non-x review on this is
that
it's a little what i'm saying i guess
i'm being loose when i say structural
learning because you truly need to do
structural learning on and parameter
estimation
so you can if you can learn the graph
and learn the parameters of the hidden
model right you learn the
the the graph and the parameters of the
heater mode
then you can check where this matches
the what is close to your
your vco guess and then you can produce
an answer on whether the visual unhidden
match
at least that that's uh that's my
understand my understanding how you
would do it
i think that's a fair answer yeah
i think it was that you're learning tv
in the end right
and also the sample complexity you
stated the n squared log n is indeed for
parameter
for learning in tv like yeah but i'm
like
that's right so you don't use the
structure it's by itself
yeah i mean you you yes you need the the
parameter estimation and client's mega
give you both right gives you the graph
and you can also estimate the parameters
and in general at least what
is import system structure learning
seems to be the main
uh obstacle once you have the graph then
estimating the parameter
it's i will say easier but
it seems doable sometimes at the same
time you can
do both at the same time
any other questions
okay so yeah let's let's move on now i
want to
give you a little bit of uh at least a
full picture actually of the ideas in in
this uh
in these proofs uh in the second for the
for the for the pod small
and essentially it's going to be a
reduction from
approximate counting to identity right
so we have these uh problems uh
in sampling and approximately something
presumably counting that we know
they are hard sometimes empty hard
sometimes sharp is hard
and we're going to use an identity in
algorithm to solve those problems
right and this will imply the the
hardness of identity testing
in particular for the photomagnetic pots
model
we know that uh sampling uncounted are
charged heart
and this is what we're going to use uh
this is a this is the harness that we're
going to infer for the testing
but i want to uh make here
a point that there is a an important
difference
in in this in this proof compared to
previous work
for instance for the phenomena for
anti-pharmaceutical symbol
and this is because
for when we prove the harness for the
anti-formative symbol uh we do a
reduction from max code right we use
the tester to solve the the max code
problem
which is a hard this is a hard problem
so you get mp harness
for for identity testing but this is
because if you look at the
anti-ferromagnetic model and you look at
the thing called the ground states which
means these are the
the configuration with the highest
probability you see that the
anti-chromatic
anti-information mode when and when the
interactions are
quite strong it's going to be supported
mostly on the max codes
right so there is this connection
between the ground states of the mall
and a well a well-known hard
optimization problem
but if now you look at the federal
magnetic platform and you look at the
ground state the ground states are
completely trivial
so the ground stay for for the magnetic
but small is just a monochromatic
configuration it will be the highest
will give you the highest probability so
you don't have this
uh hard optimization problem in the
background that you can use
in the reduction and that's that's why
uh for
for the pod small we need to to start
from uh from scratch and in particular
we prove the reduction from approximate
account
okay so there are going to be two key
gadgets in in our construction in our
reduction
and the first one is going to be the
ferromagnetic pot small and the complete
graph
and this is known as the mean field mode
and the second one
uh is is the ferromagnetic
plot small on atlanta by pythagoras so
here the second one
it's a it's uh it's going to be a degree
to using gadget that has been used
before in other
hardness of approximation harness of
counting uh
results okay so
let me tell you a little bit uh about
the federal magnetic uh
mean field
from the mean field pod small so here
the
underlying geometry is going to be the
complete so there is essentially no
geometry right
so we're looking at the pod small on the
complete graph and
because of this lack of geometry we can
think of the configurations as just
a vector in in cq right so the first
coding
will tell you how many vertices are red
second quadrant however it is a blue
and so on right so
this model has a very interesting phase
transition
so when beta is is below the
some specific threshold that we know
what it is
it's a function of q dimension is going
to concentrate
around this uniform vector where
what this says is essentially that if
you draw a sample from the distribution
it's going to be you're going to have
roughly the same number of
of of uh of colors
all first parties with the same color so
you're going to have the same number for
example here you have the same number of
blue vertices the same number of green
and the same number of threads
right and you're going to have a good
concentration
around this this type of of
configuration
but when beta is above this threshold uh
this uh
phase transition threshold now the
measure is going to
concentrate around the majority vectors
right
so these are going to be vectors that
correspond to configurations that look
like this so you have probably
it could be blue dominant right and then
this would be a large fraction
and then the remaining is going to be
equally distributed
among the other colors so you have
mostly blue and then
green and red will be about the same
or mostly green or mostly fed so the the
vectors are going to look something like
this c dim
see the lines m this is going to do the
majority and the rest is remain
is divided equally right so it's going
to we're going to have some
concentration on here
the constant theta we know we know what
it is it's a function
of q okay it's the root of some
equations and depends on
it so this is we have this phase
transition
this is this is well known it's a very
well story uh more
what we're interested in what is going
to be more important to us is what
happens exactly at the critical point
right now we set
the parameter equal to the critical
threshold
and here when q is greater equal than
three we are going to have this
phenomena called phase coexistence
okay and what happens there is that you
have
phase coexistence between the two
possible phases within the order phase
and the disorder phase so what i mean by
that is
with some product if you draw a sample
uh from the distribution
at in at the with a good temperature
with the critical interaction
you're going to get uh with say
some constant alpha this is some
constant depending on
the size of the graph you're going to
get a disorder configuration
concentrated around the
disorder the the concentrated around the
uniform
vector but with probability one minus
alpha you are going to get one of the
three
uh mostly uh mostly blue
but mostly green or mostly red when
there is one one dominant chord
right so this is called phase
coexistence because
you can have these very different
behaviors of the critical points
and this is a property of the pot small
only when q is greater than three the
mean field plots more only when q is
greater than
three for the easy mode we don't have
the type of
a transition right so this
uh matches uh what we know that for the
federal manager
pharmacy small testing is high so we
couldn't
uh push our reduction
for the ac mode just because you don't
have this type of behavior at the
critical point which is
crucial for us right it's going to have
a crucial guide
okay so just to insert some
some notation here remember that c is
the
uh this is the partition function or
normalization constant for the for the
case of the
complete graph from m vertices we're
going to use cm
and it's just the sum of all the weights
of the configuration
and it will be convenient for us to
split the contribution to this uh
partition function
think of the contribution to this
partition function in terms of a
minority configuration somehow the
configurations are going to with this
type of configurations
or disorder configurations which are
going to be this this type of disorder
configurations
or everything else right um
i'm not going to give the precise
definition but you can think of
this is the summation that includes all
the configurations that are
close to which uh
signature is close to this type of
vectors whether they sort of
the vectors that are close with some
notion of closeness
to this to his tackle patch okay um
one easy thing to prove is that uh when
beta
when we're in discrete regime this uh
the contribution from from the
configurations that that
are not either close to these or close
to this is very small and we are going
to more or less
ignore it okay so only these two type
of of uh of configurations will
contribute to the partition punch
okay so let me that this was a
a summary of uh either well-known
results or
results that are foreclosed and people
know i have not been written and
whatever about the the pharmacy but
small
what we need is this uh very specific
manifestation of of this physical
existing phenomena
is this property that says that for any
r
when in reasonable r we can pick
the value of the parameter beta so that
if we look at the ratio of
of the partition of the majority
partition function and the disorder
partition function it
is going to be roughly equal to r okay
so right let me
this is going to be important for all
for for the for our reduction so let me
just emphasize what this means right
we know that when beta is exactly equal
to beta critical we know that there is
we know that there is uh if we look at
the uh
this ratio is going to be some constant
and what this says is that i can move in
either direction from the critical point
either a little bit larger
to make the majority more dominant or a
bit smaller if i want to make a disorder
more dominant and i can do that
in a systematic way and actually make
this ratio
equals to any desire r that i want
there is also a continuity here
it's the continuity of the the partition
functions is also important
okay so this is going to be the key
property that we're going
to use in the reduction this was it's
kind of a new property but it's really
no it's right it really follows from
what was known
about the behavior of the mean female
okay um
okay so here is our construction of the
vco mode
so we have a heart canceling instance
this is
say a graph and we also have some edge
weight this is the
the graph where we don't know how to
approximately
count and what we do is that we connect
we put this very big mean field
reservoir here so we put a complete
graph here
we're going to think of m of the size of
this graph will be much larger than the
size of this graph
we're going excuse me we're going to
connect them with a complete
pattern with a complete by pi target
and the intuition here is that because
this graph is much larger than
than this one right when this graph is
in the majority phase when you have
blue dominant color here that is going
to
overwhelm the whatever uh whatever
the the distribution here is like the
same
so whenever you have a dominant color
here this graph here it's going to be
essentially the interactions here are
going to be relevant and this
this graph g is going to align with the
b graph
right but when this
graph now is is in the disorder phase
right so when you have roughly the same
color the same number of vertices in the
same color
from the point of view of this graph is
as is
if this graph is not there right because
each vertex is going to see roughly the
same number of red that's the number of
blue is the number of greens
so it's not going to feel the effect of
this big graph there right because it's
going to cancel out
okay so um again when this one is in the
majority phase it's going to completely
overrule what's going on on g
and instead you're going to align but
when this one is in the this order phase
with mostly the same number of colors
then g will
actually say how the distribution of on
the whole
vcl looks like okay
right so just to
put in symbols what i was saying with
words essentially
when this guy is in the majority phase
and now we look at the partition
function
uh the partition function uh for for the
for the reason or more
fraction of the partition model that
corresponds to the myod phase here
is going to be given essentially by the
minority phase
of of the complete graph times some
constant
right and that's because there is going
to be very little fluctuation here this
as i said this one is
we're going to the constant is just
going to be the contribution of all the
edges here
and all the edges here right because
this guy is going to align with the
this is going to be blue just like this
one and
we can account for that constitution on
a
whereas when uh
whereas when these guys in the when the
complete graph is in this order phase
now we do have the contribution
from from the front g right
so the the the partition function
for m for the visible mole corresponding
to configurations that are disorder on
the complete graph is going to be given
by
the partition function on the complete
graph here times the partition function
of g
and some constant and now it only
accounts for the edges going across it
okay now if you remember our main facts
concerning the the mean field mode it uh
it says that we can for every desire
r we can make this ratio right cm iod
and cmd sorry
to match that r and using that then we
can
actually find for any r we can find a
beta every time a parameter on this side
here
that makes this ratio equals to this to
this r
and this is uh essentially crucial to
to our reduction because what we're
going to do instead of
uh doing this reduction from approximate
accounting
testing we use reaction from decision
approximate counting
which is which approximate counting can
be reduced to this version this decision
version just by binary search but
essentially it suffices to
give an answer to to distinguish between
these two cases
of given r where c is
where the partition function of g of the
of the hard instant is much smaller than
r
or much lighter than r so if we can
distinguish between these two cases
that's enough to solve the original
approximate counting problem
so it's enough to do a reduction from
the inspection of the problem to
identity testing
and if you look at this uh fraction that
we have here
you notice that okay we are given an r
that is going to be our desired
approximation and we can find
a parameter beta for the complete graph
of the reservoir
that makes this roughly equal and then
all that we need to do is distinguish
uh where this ratio is a small or large
right because if this ratio is
small that would mean that cg has to the
partition function for you has to be
much higher than r
but if this ratio is large the opposite
happens it has to be small
okay so this is all our identity testing
uh algorithm although it needs to give
us is where
the signal that you have to give us this
way this ratio is small or large
okay and for doing that we created here
more in a specific way
so what we do is we put a complete graph
here now so this is a kind of a new mode
where instead of having a hard graph
here we put something that is completely
trivial
and these are the benefit that well one
of them is that we can
very easily generate a sample from this
theorem which we need to do because this
is what the tester do
the testing needs and the other thing is
that
this model is always going to have the
monochromatic here right it's going to
align to whatever is going
so it's always going to be monochromatic
and in particular when
this big graph here is monochromatic
this one is going to align
right so
yeah so it's exactly the same so that we
put a complete graph here
so to finalize the the reduction
remember
that that we only need to distinguish
between uh very small
we need we only need to distinguish
within these two cases either the
additional function is much smaller than
a given threshold or much larger and
this reduced to checking
where this fraction here is small or
large and what we do is that
we send to the tester the visible mode
that we constructed
and samples from the hidden mode that we
construct okay
so okay so the tester is going to give
us two the two possible answers you're
going to say
yes in which case it means that it
accepted the the
the samples of the hidden molar samples
of the from from the
from the visible one but we know that
the vco
only it's only monochromatic the the
graph g the harness has become an
aquamatic
only when we have a majority domination
or the disorder phase
right so the the fact that the test says
yes
it's saying that well the facing that is
saying is this viewing this
the the the um visible and here mo
has been closing collaboration distance
and if they are closing to the american
distance this means that this portion of
the
of the construction this one here has to
be monochromatic in both
and that's only happens when you have a
majority domination
on on this side so in that case since
the merorite dominates we can say that
the ratio is large
otherwise when it's known then the the
dopamine is going to be
uh large and that means that the
distorted phase dominates right because
now this means that
in the hidden mode here you have uh
monochromatic whereas indivisible there
you are behaving like what you see is
whatever g the hard instance
it's it's uh it's saying that you should
see
right so in that case the ratio is uh is
small
okay so that's a
deduction hopefully you the main idea of
the reduction is there hopefully you you
got some
some insights um remember that
essentially we use the identity
algorithm to solve
a bizarre problem so this implies the
the harness of
of identity the base harness widening
testing
but we are not done right uh the the
if you see our construction the degree
is blowing up right the degree is
it's large we have complete graph
emotionalizing the actual heart instance
so
polynomial degrees in general um the
good thing is that
beta the strength of the interactions is
we keep we kept it constant we'll have
to
do anything with that but definitely
there is this problem that the degree
it's uh it's unbounded but this can be
fixed
and for this we use a general strategy
also from
results proving highness of approximate
counting
for various problems and the idea is
that we generate a random bipartite
graph
random regular by part a graph and we
replace every vertex
in our previous construction by one of
these random bipartite graphs right
and then we use some of the available
degree to connect the
the internal i mean we do like let's say
epsilon d of of of the
okay some fraction of the degree we use
it to connect the graph internally but
we leave some degree
free to actually connect the vertices
okay so doing this we can dilute
the degrees of of the of the previous
construction right so if you have a
vertex to have a very
large degree then essentially you can
connect to many of these new
vertices and the random bipartite graph
that we put in
so in order for this to work we need
these gadgets
to behave like vertices and essentially
what we want is that
they are monochromatic regardless of the
the very close to the ground state
regardless of the influence that comes
from the outside we want this ones to be
mostly red mostly green mostly glue
mostly blue because a vertex
will only have one color and the
dominant color in this gadget will
essentially be
the color of the vertex and this follows
from two things the first one is that
the the
but also that's uh beta the our
parameter is it's uh
this is especially the parameters of my
offload okay
so this is back uh just to conclude this
is the initial conjecture
for our working conjecture that whenever
sampling or structural learning
or structural learning slash parameter
estimation are hard
then i guess the identity is hard in
this talk we will
i verified the conjecture for the
ferromagnetic but small
earlier work there for the antiferro
antiferro
easy mode and also in this work
and just as evidence that this this
these approaching
kind of robust for proving this this
type of results were able to show
uh similar results for rpm so
essentially we proved that
for abians whenever sampling our
learning
are hard then we also get harness of
identity testing
thank you
cool uh yeah very nice reduction thanks
to tonia so
if anybody has any questions feel free
to speak up
guess there are a number of questions
during the talk um
you want to uh do you mind saying
something uh briefly about
uh how the rbm case differs what is the
key idea or the key gadget in that case
so the the gadget is a little different
the intuition behind it is not
because it also relates to this phase
coexistent phenomena
so once we have this phase coexistent
phenomena
we do some gadgeteering to
to actually uh derive the the result it
really have the same structure
but at the moment this is why we don't
have a genetic
implication that hardness of approximate
counting implies hard enough of testing
or anything like that
there is a step of the proof that is the
construction
of this gadget based on the face of the
phase transition on the facebook system
so for rbms our constructions
are a little simpler the reservoir
instead of having a complete graph
we actually well i wouldn't say simpler
uh
yeah let's say they are different we do
a different construction outside of the
heart instance
and and we use that to in a very similar
way to
to answer yes or no to this question of
whether the partition function is
above or below some pressure
the common the the the the flow of the
proof is
it's the same uh what changes is the
specific gadget that we have to put to
capture this uh phase coexistence
but that seems to be what's uh so the
phasecoin system is what drives the
hardness of sampling and count
right this this first of the phase
transition is what implies the harness
and it seems that there is some some
connection here but it's not completely
fleshed out yeah one question
uh so when so for the tolerant
identity testing question so you're
trying to test whether
the two models are close versus far
do you expect i mean
i mean the reduction to be easier or
better reduction
because i think in that case it's also
easy when both sampling and structure
learning
is easy so you can approximate the
distance
[Music]
well if so
in this case you're saying that sampling
and social learning are easy
i mean i'm saying if sampling and
structure learning are doable
then i think you can also approximate
the distance
right testing but i
expect the hardness will be easier to
prove
for the stronger question of
approximating the distance
have you guys thought about this oh i
see so
so if you look at the yeah i saw a
little bit of to say
proving hardness of approximate the
structural learning and i see this
there are experts in the audience that
can probably answer this better
the computational harness seems open for
some very simple cases
uh so
yeah i don't know if it's going to be
easier or harder to prove but it's
definitely an
interesting they're different they're
definitely interesting open questions
cool thanks antonio um thanks everybody
for attending and
look forward to seeing everybody
tomorrow workshop
thank you